Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my new marvel x-men video we
have some good news for a change. There
are things to look forward to so there's
a new Disney Plus teaser for new marvel
x-men content and actually everyone was
going crazy this morning trying to
figure out what it means there's a lot
of x-men stuff going on behind the
scenes at Marvel Studios since they got
the rights back to all their characters
from the Fox Steel so we'll break it all
down if you're new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos
we're doing that Amazon giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave all your theories about what
this means on the video so I'll just go
down the list of the projects that
they've already talked about that we
know that they're working on and what
this is most likely going to be starting
with number 5 if you didn't see the last
day or so people started to notice that
there's a new section and Disney Plus
that started showing a bunch of new
x-men artwork like they're creating a
new destination for Marvel x-men content
in Disney Plus that's brand new x-men
content there's brand new artwork of
them in their costumes from x-men the
animated series but because all the
episodes from the classic x-men the
animated series have already been on
Disney Plus since it launched last year
all this new teaser and artwork didn't
show up connected to that stuff so
that's why everyone thinks that this is
Marvel creating a section where they're
going to be putting some new x-men
project on Disney Plus the Disney CEO
said that one of their biggest
priorities now is growing their Disney
Plus subscriber base the only way to do
that the big hook to get people to pay
for it is brand new content for the past
year Kevin Feige has been talking about
them working on new Marvel x-men
projects that's multiple different
projects when people think about that
they're mostly thinking about the new
full-blown x-men Marvel MCU movie with
rebooted versions of the characters that
is happening in the background but all
the new x-men projects that they're
working on include one-off mutants and
x-men characters being introduced in
other movies like black panther 2 or
even Captain Marvel - if rumors are to
be believed and it also includes
straight-up Disney Plus series with
x-men and mutant characters normally
when we talk about the x-men we're
talking about the core x-men team but
technically the term applies to all the
Fox Marvel characters usually only
Deadpool and the Fantastic Four are
spoken of separately even though
technically Fox had the right
Deadpool because he was included in all
the Marvel rights when they initially
licensed the characters after Marvel
went bankrupt in the 90s a lot of people
wondering if they're creating more
sections for x-men content in Disney
Plus as a precursor to releasing New
Mutants video on-demand instead of
trying to push it to way later this year
in theaters the reason why I don't think
this is connected to New Mutants though
it's just because it would probably have
some New Mutants specific artwork in all
these new teasers number four there have
been a lot of x-men Easter eggs and the
MCU in the live-action films I've
already done a couple videos recently
about that especially for the Wolverine
character so I'll link those at the end
of this so it could be the beginnings of
Marvel just creating a dedicated section
for their new live-action x-men Marvel
movie content but I think this is less
likely just because Marvel hasn't
announced a release date for that new
Marvel MCU x-men movie we just know that
it's happening at some point during
Marvel phase 5 they haven't really given
us any hints as to who they're looking
at in terms of actors and the sting of
x-men Dark Phoenix is still so fresh
they're using the next couple of years
to develop new x-men movie projects just
kind of hoping that after a bunch of
time goes by fewer people will associate
the bad x-men movies with the new x-men
movies when Marvel does start talking
about their new version of the x-men and
they just killed off Hugh Jackman's
Wolverine in the Logan movie a few years
ago Kevin Feige understands they need to
pay their respects and not rush to
recast the character right away fans
would be pissed if they rolled out a
brand-new Wolverine next year number
three there was a brand new Deadpool
animated series that almost wound up
airing on FX networks made by Donald
Glover an animation studio even released
a teaser trailer for it in everything
this is a clip from that giving you an
idea of what it would have felt like.
Oh, Bad Guys to kill!
Hey!
I've never said this. But don't swallow!
Incoming!
I promise this gets worse for you big boy!
That does it!
Aah, I'm touching myself tonight.
No joke that was going to be a rated-r
Deadpool animated series that would have
been badass but before FX could order
more episodes Marvel opted to cancel the
project mostly because they didn't like
the way Donald Glover was writing
Deadpool's jokes and using him for
social commentary you may remember this
from a couple years ago donald glover
posted all these script pages that he
wrote where he shaded Marvel TV people
hardcore but it was the Marvel TV people
it wasn't Kevin Feige in the Marvel
Studios people recently they just had
that big culling there was a huge
bloodbath now all of Marvel TV is part
of Marvel Studios and Kevin Feige
controls everything all the TV shows all
the movies and all the comics as well so
while I do think that they're still
trying to create an animated Deadpool
series because that'd be an easy
slam-dunk I don't think that that would
be part of this new Disney Plus x-men
related content just because it would be
more mature and Disney Plus is supposed
to be more pg-13 and family-friendly
stuff hopefully someday we'll see a
hardcore Deadpool animated series on
Hulu or something like that because
Disney owns Hulu now so that's where all
their Deadpool content is probably going to
live number two a little more likely
this Disney Plus x-men teaser could just
be the beginnings of an x-men
live-action Disney Plus series with
lesser mutant characters like scarlet
witch's children Wiccan in speed which
we see during the Wanda vision trailer
like a lot of people when I first saw
that footage I just assumed it was the
beginnings of Marvel doing mutants in
the MCU and because Disney Plus series
are meant to be for that pg-13 younger
audience Marvel would just start doing
the DC TV show thing on Disney Plus
where you have a bunch of interconnected
TV series but a lot of them are younger
characters really good example of that
is the Miss Marvel series that are doing
on Disney Plus she's around the same age
as Tom Hollands spider-man not that
young but also not that old either you
also have the Caped character debuting
during the Hawkeye series so there's
just a lot of really young characters
showing up on Disney Plus so it just
seems like the place if you're going to do
a big young character team-up and Young
Avengers would be an easy slam-dunk for
that but you need some of those Fox
Marvel characters but number one just
based on all the evidence and the
interviews they've done so far I think
it's most likely this new x-men teaser
is Marvel doing a new version or new
episodes of x-men the animated series
some new project related to x-men the
animated series.
I know how you feel about it Wolverine but.
You know nothin' little man!
Warner Bros and DC brought back Young Justice the
exact same way for their streaming
service DC Universe Kevin Feige is
reportedly a big fan of the classic
x-men the animated series they have a
lot of that classic content on the
service already in The Hollywood
Reporter even talked to the creators of
the original x-men the animated series
and they said that they had pitched a
revival of the series to Marvel a little
while ago so this might be Marvel
finally making good on that pitch but
like I said the real hook getting people
to subscribe to Disney Plus and pay for
it is releasing brand new content the
fun backstory on why they cancelled
x-men the animated series because I
loved watching that series when I was a
little kid reportedly Fox canceled the
series mostly because they didn't like
that Marvel still controlled their most
popular animated series and they were
getting ready to make a live-action
x-men film and this was around the time
of the Marvel bankruptcy when they were
licensing their characters out so was
right around the time that Fox gain
control of the live-action x-men
properties and they wanted full control
of the x-men characters but you still
have Marvel Studios that has the rights
to the animated series and if you're a
big fan of that classic spider-man the
animated series it's also the same
reason why they cancelled that because
that was airing around the same time as
the classic x-men the animated series.
If any part of me is anything like the real Mary Jane Watson, she loves Peter Parker
more than anything in the world. More. Than. Anything...
Nooooo!
So everyone let me know in the comments
what kind of new x-men related project
do you think that Marvel is teasing for
Disney Plus we're going to start seeing
more x-men Easter eggs and mutants
through the Disney Plus series like
Falcon and Winter Soldier in Wandavision this year so I'll be doing more
Easter egg videos for that leave all
your video requests in the comments
below
congratulations R W stew 4 your the
giveaway winner from my last big Marvel
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your details
I just did a big video for spider-man 3
and all the new canceled and delayed
Marvel movies they just announced you
can click here for that and click here
for all my brand new Marvel Wolverine
Weapon X Easter eggs in the MCU movies
thank you so much for watching everyone stay safe
I'll see you guys tonight!